we have a voicemail number which is two
one nine two david p got a voicemail
about trump and hillary yes people are
still talking about hillary clinton it's
a very specific pointed aggressive
question to me let's take a listen to it
yeah panic curious you uh when talk a
lot about all the stuffs that trump is
up to and everything and but i'm pretty
sure you voted for Hillary which tells
me that you knowingly wittingly and
without any pressure voted for lying
cheating stealing covering up it's kind
of curious how with a straight face you
can say that you don't like that when
it's pretty obvious who folded to
support that so just kind of wondering
if you could address that issue in the
air yeah okay so the question is I claim
to be opposed to the criminality of
Donald Trump but I voted for Hillary
therefore I was endorsing criminality
because Hillary is a criminal listen I
don't know that there is really a
serious conversation to have with this
individual but this is exactly the type
of false equivalence equivalency stuff
that got us Trump in the first place
because remember we're talking about a
guy who won yes with the help of foreign
countries sure but because of 77,000
votes across three states and if we had
people not falsely equating Donald Trump
and Hillary Clinton because Hillary was
going to start wars and Hillary was
going to tank the economy and Hillary
was going to do all the things that
Donald Trump has done which clearly
Hillary Clinton was not going to do you
end up with a situation where people say
listen it was exactly the same thing and
now that we realize that it's not the
same thing now that we realized that on
the climate these two could not have
been further apart now that we realized
that as far as supreme court pics and
the impact on the supreme court these
two could not have been further apart
the Hillary Trump false equivalency
pretty quickly falls apart but beyond
that criminality
come on I know all the conspiracy
theories about Hillary but if you're
going to make the case that she did
criminal things and that she's going to
end up behind bars when is the
investigation going to start I'm still
waiting around for that so give me a
break but this is the type of person
that votes so what's just important is
we're not going to convince that guy not
to vote for Trump in 2020 it would be
much easier to get 10 people who are
lukewarm about voting to go out and go
to the polls and vote and you would have
way more of an impact than wasting your
time trying to change his mind on the
bonus show today an Argentinian radio
host will avoid criminal prosecution by
discussing gender issues what's going on
in my home country we will also talk
about Japan suffering their biggest
natural population decline ever this
year in 2018 this is an ongoing issue
that we've been talking about we will
also talk about North Korea's focus on
basketball basketball an obsession of
Kim jong-un and they continue to promote
basketball as an important project for
the Republic of the Democratic People's
Republic of Korea also known as North
Korea as we call it all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show remember
January 1 2019 the biggest membership
special of the year if you want to be
notified about that membership special
simply go to david pakman.com sign up
for our newsletter and on January 1 you
will get an email with instructions on
how to take advantage of the biggest
membership special of the year exciting
stuff we will talk to you on the bonus
show